>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington, DC.
>> John Cole: Well,
good afternoon.
Welcome, welcome to the
Library of Congress.
I've just poured two
glasses of water,
one is for our speaker
and one is for me.
I'm John Cole, the Director
of the Center for the Book.
And I'm having a hoarse
voice problem this week.
But I know that I have
enough left in me to get
through this introduction,
which gives me a great deal
of pleasure to present a special
book that has a connection
with a previous book
that has appeared
in a Center for the Book series.
Let me tell you just for
a minute a little bit
about the Center for the Book.
We were created in 1977
by Daniel Boorstin,
when he was Librarian
of Congress.
And his idea was the Library
of Congress needed a
public outreach organization
to promote books and reading
really for the general public
and to get out and publicize the
importance of books and reading
and literacy and libraries.
And while it includes scholarly
books -- such as today's,
which is published by the
University of Georgia Press --
actually the emphasis in
many ways was on outreach
and even on new media.
And our very first project,
starting in 1979, was with,
believe it or not,
CBS Television,
and it was called,
Read More About it.
And when CBS had a program,
the star of the program --
some of you may remember those,
they lasted for about a decade.
The star of the program came
out and said, if you've enjoyed
that program, the Library
of Congress suggests you go
to your local library
and bookstore.
For heaven's sake, don't go
to the Library of Congress.
I said that, that wasn't
part of the message.
Go to your local library or
bookstore, they'll be happy
to help you read more about it.
But the fun part
of that for us was,
it helped us develop
partnerships with book sellers
and with libraries
and with others.
And that got us started
in what will be in 2017,
the 40th anniversary of our book
and reading promotion project.
One of our major projects is
the National Book Festival.
How many of you have been to
the National Book Festival?
Several of you, I hope.
It's a wonderful
Library of Congress event
in which the Center for
the Book plays a key role.
And we're very proud of the
strategic role that we play.
We also reach out to the
states kind of in the spirit
of Dr. Boorstin through creating
affiliated Centers for the Book
that promote books and reading
and often state authors.
And so for example, you know,
there is a Texas
Center for the Book.
There's one for each state.
And we work with them on several
different kinds of projects.
But one of them turns out to
be the National Book Festival,
because there is a pavilion of
the states that people from all
over the country come
to show their wares.
This year's festival was at the
Washington Convention Center
and was enormously successful.
And we're eagerly making plans
for what will be the 16th
National Book Festival.
I hope that you will watch the
newspaper and stay in touch
with us to learn when
it's going to occur.
Another important activity
here at the Library
of Congress is this
kind of talk .
We call this Books and Beyond.
And the idea is to honor
authors and new books
that have been published just
recently that relate to if not
to the collections of
the Library of Congress,
at least to other libraries
and research institutions.
So we could always make the
point that all the research
and hard work and editing
that go behind books,
often they indeed do still get
published and do still get sold
and are still really major
ways of sharing information.
So these noontime talks are
also filmed for the Library
of Congress's website.
So before we start,
I'd like to invite you
to turn off all things
electronic
and to say just a
word about our format.
That will be a presentation by
our author Carol McCabe Booker,
but also then a chance for
a question-and-answer period
and a book signing to follow.
And there are books for sale,
and I hope you'll take advantage
of that and talking to Carol
a bit about of the book
and about the remarkable
person who she's writing about.
Alice Dunnigan is going to be
the topic of our talk today.
Our author -- our editor
author, Carol McCabe Booker,
has condensed Dunnigan's 1974
self-published autobiography
to appeal to a broader
audience and annotated it.
And Carol is going to be able
to tell you all about that.
What I've learned a
little bit from our own --
from looking at the book
and from our own press
release is something else
that will be a major topic, and
that is Alice Dunnigan herself,
who turns out to be
quite a remarkable person
and is a pioneer in the
Black Press Movement
through her achievements.
And I must say that -- and I
will again defer to our author
to give you more details.
Carol herself is
a special person.
Carol McCabe Booker is a
former journalist in Washington
and also especially a
Washington attorney.
But the Center for the
Book had the good fortune
of sponsoring just about
two years ago this month,
a book with her husband,
journalist Simeon Booker.
There was a program we had
over in the Whittall Pavilion,
another one of the
library's buildings.
And it was called, Shocking the
Conscience, a Reporter's Account
of the Civil Rights Movement.
So you can see that
today's presentation
and the previous presentation
are both celebrating the civil
rights anniversaries
that are very much part
of what the Library is doing.
And Simeon is here and I
would like him to raise a hand
and let's give him a round of
applause, who is the author.
[ Applause ]
The co-author at that time of
what was a and what remains
to be a remarkable book.
At this time though I would
like to introduce Carol,
who not only will tell you how
she managed to put this together
but I think give you
a new appreciation
of this important pioneer
of National Black
Press, Alice Dunnigan.
Let's welcome Carol.
[ Applause ]
>> And I'll take my
glass of water if I may.
>> Carol McCabe Booker:
Thank you, Dr. Cole.
And thank you all for coming.
It gives me great pleasure
to talk about this book here
in the Library of Congress.
Because the rebirth
of the autobiography
of Alice Dunnigan
took place largely
because of the help I
received from the staff
of the Library of Congress.
First of all, I fell in love
with Alice Dunnigan right
across the street in
the Jefferson Building,
under that magnificent dome
over the main reading room.
And then, I decided right then
and there, more people have
to be able to read this book.
But to do it, it
needed annotation,
it needed some updating --
although she had a
lot of good footnotes
in it -- it needed some more.
And that's where I got a
lot of help from the staff
of the Library, particularly
the newspaper and periodicals,
reading room, where I
found access to many
of the old newspapers, the Black
Press papers, that are available
on the ProQuest and
other databases.
So you can see what
she wrote about.
Because Alice Dunnigan, while
you may not have heard of her,
she did more than any
other journalist of her era
to keep black Americans
informed about what was going
on in the struggle
for civil rights.
And I can say that
without any fear
of anybody contradicting it,
because of the numbers alone.
She wrote headline front
page stories for more
than 100 black newspapers
across the country.
And they included
the most influential,
the Chicago Defender,
the Pittsburgh Courier,
the Norfolk Journal and Guide,
as well as the New York
Amsterdam News, the Baltimore
and Washington Afro, the
Kansas City Plaindealer,
the Oklahoma Dispatch, the Los
Angeles Sentinel, on and on.
People learned what was
going on in the Congress,
in the White House, in
Washington, in politics,
and also, out of Washington.
Because she wasn't going
to be kept just here.
Alice wanted to go
where the news was,
and she wanted to report it.
Why don't we know about her?
Well, look at the times.
First of all, we think of the
Civil Rights Movement starting
with the Montgomery bus boycott.
That's not really true.
There were a lot of things
going on in the '40s and '50s.
And one of Alice's purposes
in writing her book was
to let you know that.
The other thing she makes
very clear in her introduction
to the book is she wants
it to be remembered,
the role of the Black Press
and black writers generally
in making known what she called
"the shenanigans" of whites
in trying to keep down
the black population.
Without black writers and black
journalists, the Black Press,
she said, a lot of that
would've been lost.
The other thing she wanted to
do in writing this book was
to inspire young women
never to give up.
And in that regard, looking
back on this magnificent career,
she asks one favor from
us, one little request.
She said, please do not
judge me by the heights
to which I have risen but by
the depths from which I came.
That's paraphrasing
Frederick Douglass,
but it's it's Alice Dunnigan.
And that's why I want to
look back to where she began
in Depression -- pre-Depression
era and then coming
through Depression,
in a border state.
Now, a border state, Kentucky,
was different from
the deep South.
And that became apparent
as she told her story.
Before I get on to all of that,
let me tell you how I
got involved in this.
Dr. Cole very kindly mentioned
my husband, Simeon Booker.
Admittedly, an icon
of the Black Press
and the Civil Rights Movement.
He was inducted into
the National Association
of Black Journalists Hall
of Fame the same night
as Alice Dunnigan, she
was inducted posthumously.
He was 94x.
It was a great evening,
January 2013.
And they mentioned
at the time --
Paul Brock, one of the
founders of the NABJ --
mentioned that both of
them had written books
about the events they covered.
Simeon's had just came out.
So it was a great time
for this induction.
And Paul Brock mentioned that,
through this new electronic
miracle and computers and all,
people right there in the
audience could order a copy
of his book by taking their
smartphone and wiping it --
swiping it across a cue,
something code in an ad
that the University Press of
Mississippi took in the program.
And then he said,
oh, but, please,
wait and do it afterwards.
As I'm thinking, wait a
minute, let them do it now!
This is 50 years of this man's
life went into this book!
Why are we waiting?
We went on with the program
and they mentioned Alice
had also written a book.
And I remember this.
I had met Alice Dunnigan
at a jet Christmas party
and at other social functions,
but I never really knew her.
I came to Washington in '66.
By then, she had moved onto
her third career, in politics,
working in the White House.
So I didn't really know much
about her journalism career.
So when they mentioned
that she had self-published
in 1974 a memoir, an
autobiography, called,
A Black Woman's Experience from
Schoolhouse to the White House,
the Autobiography
of Alice Dunnigan.
I said, cool, I want
to read this.
It's about time.
Well, I got a little surprise.
When I went looking
for it online --
as most of us do when we go
looking for a book we want
to read at home, kicking back,
and taking our time
-- I couldn't find it.
A little more searching, I found
it available from a few old,
rare booksellers for over $100.
Now, I wanted to read
it but I didn't want
to read it that badly.
So then I started
looking at libraries.
You couldn't find it except
in the reference sections.
And luckily, the Library of
Congress had it, of course,
and I live just a
few blocks from here.
So I ordered it from off-site,
came over, started reading it.
And as I said, I fell in
love with Alice Dunnigan.
Although, I must say, you got to
know maybe more than you wanted
to know, because the
book was over 670 pages.
And it took several
visits to read it.
And when I finished, I realized
that of the three sections --
Growing up in Kentucky,
Coming to Washington,
and then Leaving Journalism in
1960 to work in the White House
as an education consultant
with, oh, first it was the EEOC
and then it was the President's
Council on Youth Opportunity --
that part was less compelling
than the earlier part.
And I wanted people
to read this book.
So as one reviewer
said loving later on,
I took a machete to
it, I'll admit it.
I lobbed off the last
third of the book.
But anyone who wants to do
that research into that era,
it's there, they can go,
they can look for it.
It's in the reference section.
But the rest of it, the two
earlier parts, are so compelling
that it should be
available to anybody.
And I sent out a proposal to
three academic publishers,
all three wrote back immediately
and said they wanted this book.
One of them, thought, the
University of Georgia,
recognized that this
book should be priced
so that people can buy
it, not just libraries.
One library -- one publisher
wanted to charge $45.
I said, no.
So it's available now
at a reasonable price.
Some day hopefully
it will also come
out as a young readers edition.
Because Alice really wanted
to reach the young readers.
And anybody who has read it
knows, it has great appeal
to the I would say 9
to 16-year-old group.
And I'm hoping that
that happens.
But let me talk about what she's
talking about when Alice says,
judge me if we're
going to judge me,
and we do whether
we want to or not.
Judge me by the depths
from which I came.
Alice was born in
1906 in a rural part
of Kentucky, Logan County.
And she wanted to go to
school so desperately
from the time she
was four years old.
And it isn't that
Alice was thinking, oh,
my great intellect,
I must go to school.
Alice was lonely.
She lived on a hill about 4
miles outside of Russellville,
which was a small
town of only 5000.
There were no other
kids her age.
So she starts off wanting
to walk the 4 miles
to Russellville to
Sunday school.
But then as she goes to
school, she becomes an admirer
of the Sunday school
teacher, Miss Auletta Vaughn.
Miss Auletta Vaughn is respected
and she's lovely and she gets
in front of audiences
and she talks to people.
And little Alice says,
I want to be just
like Miss Auletta
when I grow up.
So she goes to school
every day, snow, whatever.
Her father thinks she's crazy.
Her mother bundles her up.
She walks off by herself.
The only other kid around
is an 11-year-old brother
who doesn't want anything
to do with this little girl.
He's half brother.
And he finds her embarrassing.
But pretty soon she
comes to the realization
that there are three careers
available to a black woman
in Kentucky at this time.
One of them is to
pursue an education
and become a schoolteacher.
The other two are to
work as a domestic
or to work in the fields.
Her father is a sharecropper.
Her mother takes in laundry.
She just does not want
that life for herself.
And so she pursues
the schooling.
To the degree where she becomes
the valedictorian of the class.
She graduates.
It's a fascinating story
of how she pursues getting
onto teacher education.
But let me jump ahead.
Somebody said in writing
about her recently,
he implied that she was timid.
Well, let me just touch on
some of the things in her life
that show us that right
from a little kid,
Alice was never ever timid.
And if there's one thing
we should take away
and tell young girls today is,
you don't get anywhere
by being timid.
But Alice goes to her first
job, which is 30 miles away
from home, in Mount Pisgah.
Mount Pisgah consists
of all of five houses,
a church, and a rundown school.
The nearest town is about 8
miles away, Trenton, Kentucky.
Big population, 800.
She is way out in the boonies.
She takes one look at the school
and she doesn't say anything
because she's so pleased, so
proud to have her first job.
She's 18 years old.
But she walks, in
the roof is leaking.
The windows, two
windows on each side
that should be there are covered
with yellowing cardboard.
The floor is roughhewn
wood, bare,
and when you walk
on it, dust rises.
There are no desks.
There are old church
pews that been discarded.
And cold. The teacher being the
first one to arrive at seven
in the morning has to go
out and shovel the coal
which is just dumped
in the yard,
into this potbelly
stove that's rigged up.
And rain or shine, the room
has to be kept warm that way.
And then she gets
the real bad news.
Well, second bad, second bad.
45 students on average.
65 are enrolled.
45 on average come
to the school.
And that's pretty good.
Because in a rural area, folks
have to keep the kids home
to work in the fields
and this bad weather
and the long distance to travel.
45 kids grades one
through eight in one room.
I kind of had to
stop right there.
I'm thinking, oh my
God, I couldn't do this.
This doesn't phase Alice.
One fact does, nobody
in the recollection
of all the townspeople,
of all the people,
the parents of those
schoolchildren --
nobody recalls anyone ever
graduating from this school
from the eighth grade.
Now, what you had to do to
graduate in this county,
Todd County, was to pass a
test, same test for the black
and the white students.
And Alice knows right off
the bat, these black kids are
as smart as their
white counterparts.
So it's not that.
She figures either they drop
out because boys especially
are encouraged to drop
out by the sixth grade.
It's not manly to
stay in school.
You've got to get out and flex
your muscles and work behind
that mule and show
that you're a man.
So even her brother, he quits
by the time he's
in the sixth grade.
So she said, maybe they don't
bother to take the test,
they don't graduate
from the eighth grade.
Or maybe they're intimidated
because they think maybe
the grading is going
to be weighed against them.
Or maybe they're
just not prepared.
And she says, I am going
to prepare these students.
She's got three who
are ready to graduate,
three girls, 16, 17, and 18.
She makes that her top goal.
And to jump ahead
again, she succeeds.
In the meantime though, here's
her first month on the job.
At the end of the month, she
goes down to the county seat.
She gets her check, $65.
More money than she's ever
seen in her entire life.
And she decides to see the
white school superintendent.
And she goes in with a
long list of improvements
that she wants made
in the school.
He is not happy.
And she is not timid.
Alice presents this list,
but she is so gracious.
Her son describes
her as persistent.
If she asks you for something
on Monday and you don't give it
to her, she'll be back
on Tuesday and Wednesday
and Thursday, till she gets it.
But she is the loveliest,
politest, determined woman.
So she's going to
reason with this man,
as she will people
throughout her career, reason.
Well, he quickly sees that
a floor with dust rising
from it is not healthy and
they're going to have a lot
of health problems
with these kids.
So he gives her some oil
to throw on the floor
to tamp down the dust.
He realizes a leaky
roof is a bad idea.
And he realizes that windows
that don't keep out the cold
and that don't let in the
light, not a good idea.
So they're going
to get new windows.
And then he says, you know,
I have a warehouse full
of old desks that have been
thrown out of white schools.
He says, if you can bring
somebody up here, they're yours.
And so she does.
So Alice pursues her teaching
career along these lines.
There are times when
she gets a job in one
of the Rosenwald schools.
Which, you know, were
a great improvement.
Came about through a friendship
between Julius Rosenwald
of Chicago, philanthropist,
and Booker T. Washington.
So they're a step up.
But mostly, she's in there,
she's fighting all the way.
But this is not what gets Alice.
Alice is an activist
from day one.
This is another reason
why we know,
there's no timidity
in this woman.
When she was a little kid,
her mother would take her
down to Russellville
on Saturday,
where everybody went
on Saturdays.
You went to buy anything
that you needed.
You went to meet friends,
chat on the corner,
hang out for a while.
Well, it only one
bathroom for women.
And it was in the courthouse.
And it had a sign on
it, "white ladies."
Alice had walked right in there
when she needed to
use the bathroom.
To the point where her
mother said to her, Alice,
one of these days one of
them white women is going
to beat you half to death and
they ain't nothing I'm going
to be able to do about it.
Well, Alice didn't
care, she kept right on.
That sign stayed there till well
after the Civil Rights
Act was passed,
because if nobody made
them take it down,
they weren't going
to take it down.
But a number of things
like this.
She was not complacent
and it was the complacency
that got her.
Finally, when she's
about 38 years of age,
she tries to organize a civic
league so that women who worked
as domestics would demand
at least a minimum wage.
She tried to get
them to say, hey,
if you're not delivering the
mail to black neighborhoods
because the roads aren't
paved, well, pave the roads,
and that kind of thing.
Well, everybody sat
there and said, yeah,
oh, yeah, oh, great idea.
Then they went home and told
their white employers on her.
She worked for the
school system,
so her job was immediately
in jeopardy.
That and an incident right
in the drug store downtown
where she wanted to buy a
Coke to wash down some aspirin
because she had a migraine
headache, and the clerk looks
at her and says, we don't
sell Coke to coloreds.
She goes outside,
she's sick on the curb.
She's not anonymous by
then, because she's doing
such a good job,
people know who she is.
So a woman walking by says,
ain't that the teacher
from Adairville?
And Alice -- she's
so humiliated.
She's wondering, do
they think I'm drunk?
Do they think I'm crazy?
It's just the end.
She prays like crazy
to get out of Kentucky.
And then the war comes along.
And she sees a noticed, like so
many people across the country,
especially women, a notice
hanging up in the post office.
The government was recruiting
typists to work in Washington.
She filled out the form
saying she'd worked anywhere,
could leave anytime.
So she had to go in and
take the typing test.
Well, there were no
typewriters available.
She hauled her own
that she had gotten,
a used typewriter somewhere.
She hauls it in, even
though it's unreliable,
some of the letters are crooked.
She takes the test.
She's nervous.
But the postmaster says, wow she
did so well on the written part,
he says, just calm down, take
the typing test over again.
She does and she passes.
She gets a telegram on Wednesday
before Thanksgiving saying,
report to Washington 9 am
at a government agency.
She's on the train, out of
Russellville that Sunday,
onto a whole new life.
That's just a hint.
A friend of mine who happens
to be here today was reading
the book a couple of months ago.
And a few chapters into this,
she called me and she said,
I'm reading Alice
Dunnigan's book.
And I paused.
She was waiting for
me to say something.
I was holding my breath.
And she said, I love her.
You read this book, you
will love Alice Dunnigan.
And she tells these
stories so matter-of-factly,
particularly during
the Depression.
She gets one of these
make-work jobs from the WPA,
only because she goes in
and raises heck over it.
They're only giving these jobs
to white women, to mend books,
sew clothes for kids,
nothing for black women.
So she makes a fuss
and they decide, okay,
they have black women
doing things
like cleaning public buildings.
Weren't many of them
in Russellville.
When they finish that, okay,
pull up the onion grass
in the black cemetery,
finish that.
Okay, go over to
the white cemetery.
Well, they didn't
have any onion grass
in the lovely white cemetery.
So they had them
scrubbing the tombstones.
Well, while there, they could
see the garbage truck coming
out of town once a week
and dropping its load
into the town dump.
And then the black
women race would
over there once the truck
was gone, race over there
and find whatever
produce had been dumped
that still had some life in
it, that was still edible.
She described how
you took the cabbage
and you cut off the rotten part
and you cooked the rest of it.
If the milk was -- if the meat
was beginning to get moldy,
well, you just cut
off the bad part,
soaked it overnight,
and cooked it.
But there was no, oh, poor
me, oh, feel sorry for me.
It was more like a,
here's how to get
by if tough times
ever come your way.
It was like very matter-of-fact.
She is a journalist, she
writes like a journalist.
She doesn't write
like Langston Hughes.
She's not a poet.
So when people say she
wasn't a great writer --
I asked my husband.
What do you make of that?
He said, you don't have
to be a great writer
to be a great reporter.
You just got to tell
it like it is.
So she comes on to Washington.
She works in the government.
She works her way up.
She makes a fuss.
She describes herself as a
flea in the collar sometimes.
So then the war ends and
these jobs are eliminated.
Well, at the same time,
she had been freelancing --
as she did throughout her
career -- as a teacher .
She would freelance
for the Black Press.
She was freelancing for
the Associated Negro Press,
which was a news service founded
by Claude Barnett in 1919,
which served 110 black
newspapers across the country
and about 70 in West Africa,
some of them Francophone,
Africa.
So fortunately, Claude Barnett
needs a Washington bureau chief
at that time.
His bureau chief is leaving.
Alice prevails upon him
to give her a chance.
Well, he's much rather have
a man, he makes that clear.
But he can't get a man.
His letters -- which are at the
Chicago Historical Society --
show that he offered two
men much greater salaries
than he ever paid Alice.
But he gives her a chance.
And he'll prove, as time goes
on, Claude Barnett is a sexist.
But so was just about every
other newspaperman in existence.
So he offers her one
half cent a word.
She tries that for a week.
She makes about 25 bucks and she
says, nobody can live on this.
So he doubles it to one
penny a word for his stories.
Believe me, she was prolific.
So finally, he offers
her a salary.
But as I said, never as
much as he offered a man.
Well, you know, where's
the mystery there?
According to the latest
report on pay parity for women
in this country, it will be
2058 before we reach pay parity
across the board.
I won't be alive then.
So what's up with that?
This is just nothing new.
But there was nothing
she could do about it.
She was very grateful
to have the job.
So Claude Barnett's method
of covering the news is
mainly clip and paste.
You know, clip the white papers,
send off stories, talk to maids,
talk to butlers, talk
to chauffeurs, talk
to court clerks.
And not to make a pain
in the neck of yourself.
This was not Alice's
way of proceeding.
She wanted to be wherever
the white press was.
So she tells him, that's
what she's going to do.
Okay, he just, okay.
So her first assignment is
to cover the Senate debate
over the ouster of Senator
Theodore Bilbo of Mississippi
for conduct unbecoming a senator
campaign-finance irregularities.
She goes to Capitol Hill.
She's waiting in this long line
of spectators who want to get in
and see the proceedings.
And she's so frustrated.
She realizes she'll never get
in in time to get her story.
And then she also finds out --
even if she had gotten in --
it's against the rules to take
notes while you're in there.
But she sees these men
walking by and going
up a stairway that's
cordoned off with red velvet
with two capitol
policemen standing there.
And she realizes,
they're newsmen.
So she says, here I go.
She follows them.
The cops stop her and say,
where do you think you're going?
She says, I'm going
wherever you they're going.
So the cop says, well, I don't
think you belong up there,
but if not, they'll
let you know.
She goes up the stairs.
She opens the doors.
And she's looking upon --
this is a woman who does not
have an office in Washington.
No secretary.
No typewriter.
No wire service.
Here is this fantastic layout
for members of the
Capitol Press.
They have Western
Union machines.
They have lounge chairs.
They have mimeograph.
They have forms for
sending in their copy.
And then beyond that,
those doors through which
they enter the galley
and can watch the proceedings.
And a man comes up to her
and asks her she's doing
and she says, well, I came
to watch the debate
of Senator Bilbo.
And he says, well, you
have to be a member.
She's says, fine, how
do I become a member?
And he says, well, we actually
have too many members now,
there isn't enough
room for all of them.
And she says, really?
And how many of them are Negro?
Well, actually -- so he
gives her a form to fill out.
Well, it turns out, there's no
rule against a black member.
But the rule is what we
call disparate impact.
It says, you have to be a
writer for the daily press.
All the black papers
at that time,
except perhaps the Atlanta Daily
World, were weekly newspapers,
ergo, no black members.
Well, she campaigns, campaigns.
She calls Claude Barnett and
says, I want to go after this.
I want your backing.
And he says, what makes you
think that you, a woman,
can get in where men have not
succeeded all these years?
And she says, well,
I'm going to try.
So she does and she actually
gets the rule changed.
They change the rule to
allow the weekly press in.
But she's not the
first one admitted.
Because Claude Barnett is so
sure she's not going to make it,
he doesn't send in the necessary
letter of recommendation.
So Louis Lautier, who
works for the competing
at the time called Negro
Newspaper Publishers
Association, he's the first one
in, she's the second member.
Well, she goes on
from there, she says,
how about the White House?
She goes down to -- the House
and Senate are Republican
controlled.
She goes down to the
Democratic-controlled White
House and she says, well, this
is what the Republicans did
for us, what are
you going to do?
And Charlie Ross, who's Truman's
press secretary, he says,
no problem, just
send in a letter.
So she does and she
doesn't even ask
for Claude Barnett's support.
So she gets into the
White House Press Corps.
She's the first black
woman admitted.
And then shortly after, she
notices in the press room,
a notice that the president is
going to take an 18 state tour,
whistle stop tour, of the West.
It's considered nonpolitical.
But, of course, it's
just the preparatory
to his deciding he's
going to be a candidate
for his own four-year term.
So she says, well, I want to go.
So how do I how do this?
So Charlie Ross says, no
problem, just sign up,
and it's $1000 per reporter.
Well, she tries not
to show her surprise.
She assumed that the White
House would pay the way
for any reporter
that went along.
He told her no, no, each press
outlet pays their own way.
So she goes back and she
calls Claude Barnett herself
long distance.
And Claude Barnett says,
this is not the kind
of trip a woman takes.
And she says, I want to go.
And he says, well, is
it worth $1000 to you?
And she says, yes.
And he says, well, it
isn't worth it to me
or any of my member papers.
Well, she says, I'm
going anyway,
as long as I have
your permission.
Obviously she needs his consent
because she needs
the credentials.
So he says, okay, I'll
ask my largest newspaper.
So he consults the
Chicago Defender,
the Pittsburgh Courier, and
the Norfolk Journal and Guide.
The latter is not
interested at all.
The other two, who were
highly competitive, say, well,
we might as well
send our own, man.
So they send two men
along on this trip.
So now there's three
black members
of the press going
and one woman.
Doris Fleeson, who was
reporting for the New York Post,
she went along only to Detroit.
So for most of the trip,
Alice is the only woman
on the whole trip.
Well, she's newly
arrived in Washington.
She's never covered
anything like this.
You can imagine, getting
into an assignment like this
without any experience.
So she goes to this
car on the train
where they mimeograph all
the president's speeches
and they have canned
background reports and all kinds
of paper everywhere, and
she's trying to gather
up every little bit
of information.
And then Eddie Folliard,
Pulitzer prize-winning reporter
for the Washington Post -- who
had covered every president back
to Calvin Coolidge -- he comes
up to her and he says, Alice,
you don't do it that way.
I'll tell you how to
cover this kind of trip.
You get off the train
at every stop,
you mingle with the people.
You ask them questions.
You get quotes.
You kind of take their pulse
on how they feel
about the president.
And that's what makes
your story unusual.
So pretty soon she's
writing and true,
as she called it,
Folliard style.
But she's got another challenge.
She's writing for
only the Black Press.
So as Claude Barnett
makes perfectly clear,
she's got to have a black angle.
Well, in many of these towns out
West, there weren't any blacks.
So she didn't a black angle.
So she was not about
to have no story.
Most of these stops, the other
two guys from Chicago and Pitts,
they didn't even bother
to get off the train.
They figured no black angle.
Alice found a black angle.
She writes, there was not
a single Negro in the crowd
at such and such a place
when such and such happened.
And then she'd go on with
whatever interesting happened
in that town.
Well, then one night
in Missoula, Montana,
a college town -- they weren't
supposed to stop at all.
It was midnight and
everybody had gone to bed.
But they got word that a
crowd of college students,
several hundred, had gathered
along the tracks in hopes
of seeing the president.
And Harry Truman comes
out on that platform
at the end of the last car.
They stop the train.
And in his pajamas and
robe, Harry Truman talks
to the students, and
then he takes questions.
Now, up to this point, nobody
had mentioned civil rights.
Civil rights was
not popular in 1947
and for several years
thereafter.
So the politician
didn't bring it up.
But one of those students did.
All of a sudden a hand
goes up in the crowd
and this young man
yells, Mr. President,
what do you say about
civil rights?
And the President shoots back,
I say civil rights is as old
as the Constitution and as new
as the Democratic
platform of 1944.
And then he intimates
that it will be included
in the platform of 1948.
And Alice has her
story, a nice exclusive.
And the headline is, pajama clad
President defend civil rights
at midnight.
Well, they go on.
There is only one nasty -- oh,
it only last a minute or so --
racial incident, out
in Cheyenne, Wyoming.
And it's handled and
Alice is cool with it.
Everything is fine.
A few days later, she's
sitting in her compartment
at the end of the day.
There's no stops scheduled.
She kicks off her
shoes and puts her feet
up on the seat opposite hers.
And she takes one of those
little tray tables and puts it
across her lap, puts the
typewriter on her lap,
and starts to bang out her copy.
There's a little tap on the
door and the door opens,
and it's President Truman.
And he says, I heard you
had some trouble back there.
And if anything ever
happens again,
I want you to make
sure I'm told about it.
And Alice is just never
the same after that.
She never felt so
secure in her life.
And she never felt so that --
you know, here's the
President coming to me.
And I can do fine
in any audience --
and this kind of
thing, experience,
it really fits her very well.
Later on when she's covering the
news conferences, she does fine
at Truman's news conferences,
which are held in
the Oval Office.
But then they grew
larger and moved next door
to the old executive
office building,
which was the State Department.
And Eisenhower held
them in the Treaty Room.
Well, she carried forward
through her same protocol,
which was to bring forward
civil rights issues.
Because none of the white
press ever raised a civil
rights issue.
So each time she would bring
to light some problem
going on in the government.
Questions like, is the
administration going
to do anything about the
situation at the Bureau
of Engraving, where apprentice
plate makers are not admitting
black apprentices.
And this Federal Employment
Practices Committee has found
that that's a violation
of their civil rights
and the Civil Service
Commission has agreed.
But the Bureau Engraving
isn't doing anything.
So Alice brings this up
at a news conference.
And the President gets annoyed.
Eisenhower had a very short
fuse at these conferences.
As he explained in his staff
explained, he wanted to be able
to answer any question
that came up.
So he wanted to know the field.
He didn't know much
about civil rights.
And it was, you know,
controversial,
he really didn't want
to answer questions.
Every question she asked
was along those lines.
Finally she was asked to submit
her questions in advance.
But she wasn't about
really to do that.
She tried it once,
it didn't work,
and she realized
she was being had.
But Eisenhower had his own
way of dealing with it.
He completely ignored her
for the rest of his term.
In his first few years, he
had called on her four, five,
six times at these
news conferences.
Which was a pretty good rate.
And then nothing.
Alice became the invisible woman
at Eisenhower's news
conferences.
To the effect, she would
stand up like everybody else,
Mr. President, Mr. President.
One white reporter
says to her after one
of the news conferences,
do you realize how many times
you were on your feet today?
And she says, no,
I wasn't counting.
And he says, 15.
Well, finally it
makes the White Press.
Drew Pearson, the
columnist, several newspapers,
they point out that Eisenhower
is ignoring this member
of the Black Press deliberately.
Well, he calls on her a few
years later when they're going
to televise, tape for
television, a news conference,
because he wants to show that he
recognizes a black news person.
But other than that,
he ignores her.
And then, she takes a
leave of absence to work
in the Kennedy campaign.
Then she goes back
after Kennedy is elected
to covering the White House.
Eight minutes into his first
news conference in January 1961,
JFK calls on Alice Dunnigan,
the first black woman,
first black reporter
to be called
on in this news conference.
And she says in her
lovely Kentucky drawl --
which I cannot imitate
because I am from the Bronx.
She says, Mr. President, does
your administration intend
to do anything to help the
black farmers of Fayette County,
Tennessee, who dared to
vote in the last election
and have been evicted
from their homes
and are now forced
to live in tents?
And without hesitation, JFK
comes back with, yes, we do.
I supported the Civil
Rights Act,
referring to the Civil Rights
Act such as it was of 1958,
and the Justice Department
is charged
with enforcing the voting
rights of every American.
And we intend to pursue
this situation with vigor.
And thus ends Alice
Dunnigan's purdah
at White House news conferences.
Shortly after that,
she leaves the press
and gets a political
appointment.
And from then on, she can
at least live decently,
because it's been hand to
mouth, pointing her watch
on Fridays, and a rough life.
And finally she becomes
a government employee.
And she lives out
till she was 77.
She writes her memoirs.
And the problem is, it's
very popular at the time.
And the Black Press,
she gets very good press
from the Africo-American.
But now the book is
largely unavailable.
And so it brings me here today.
And I'd be delighted
to take your questions.
I hope I haven't
run on too long.
Thank you.
[ Applause ]
Any questions?
Yes.
>> Can you talk about the
picture that was up that's
on the front of the book?
>> I'd be delighted.
That picture was taken
by Scurlock Studios.
Now, Addison Scurlock started
a photography studio here
in Washington, as the Museum
of African-American History
is well aware, in 1911.
And in the late '30s,
he was joined
by his two sons,
Robert and George.
And they became the
photographers
of the black middle class.
There are fantastic
pictures of people
like Ralph Bunche,
etcetera, etcetera.
I mean, that was the
studio you went to.
And Alice commissioned or,
you know, she hired one
of the Scurlocks, I don't know
if it was Robert or George --
I'm thinking probably Robert
-- to take this picture.
And then she would send it
out to the members of the ANP,
let them know that she was
there person here in Washington.
There's one curious
little thing.
If you look on the cover
of the book, this picture,
she's holding --
and you can see it.
She's holding the
Washington Post.
And there's a story in there,
but I don't know what it is.
Because the Washington Post did
not have any black reporters
until 1951.
And I know that because
my husband, Simeon Booker,
was the first black reporter
that Phil Graham brought in.
And it was two years --
very, very difficult years.
Because the newsroom was not
ready, despite the intentions
of the management of the Post.
And then he left
and went to Chicago
and joined Jet and
Ebony magazines.
But I'm just wondering
if Alice was trying
to identify the scenes so that
people wouldn't think it was any
ole state capital behind her,
or if there was a little joke
in there, I don't know.
But anyway, she's holding
the Washington Post,
and it's a lovely picture.
Yes?
>> Did she ever marry
or have any children?
>> Yes, Alice married twice.
She was Alice Allison.
She married twice.
The first was when
she was only 19.
After one year in
rural Mount Pisgah.
She married the church organist.
And he seemed to
be so supportive
and such a lovely young man.
But it didn't take
long before it turned
out he was not only a
mama's boy, he wanted her
to leave teaching and come join
the family as sharecroppers.
She had worked all of her
life to get out of that.
She wasn't about to give it up.
And you only taught school
five months out of the year,
the rest of the time the
kids were in the fields.
So the rest of the time,
she had to earn money.
So they would work as --
she would be a laundress.
She would take care
of the dairy.
of white children.
Cleaned white families' homes.
Whatever needed to be done.
But they had a very,
very hard time.
And her clothes became
so shabby --
and clothing to Alice was
a symbol of her dignity,
your status, the
respect that due you.
And when her shoes became
so shabby, she was ashamed
to go to Sunday school.
She told her husband
Walter, I'm not going.
And she said, I can't show up
in school looking this way.
And he said, I don't care if
you never leave the house again.
Oh, he was just dreadful.
And then two weeks later, she
said, well, this isn't working.
So she said, I'll show you, I'm
going to Sunday school anyway,
and let people see these
shabby shoes, and they'll know
that you won't let
me get decent shoes.
And he said I thought the most
astonishing thing, he said,
I don't care if you go to
church looking like the devil.
So Alice -- then she has
to go back to school.
And to do that, she has to stay
in another town for the week
and then come home on weekends.
Well, he's not going to have
anything to do with that
and he tells her, if she
leaves, she can just stay away.
And she says, well,
that's an idea.
And after five years, from
19 till the age of 24,
she and Walter split up.
A year later, a young man who
was five years older than she --
two years younger than
her brother and played
with her brother but
didn't want anything to do
with little Alice -- Charles
Dunnigan comes back to town,
having left school in the sixth
grade and gone off to the north,
become very worldly,
married, widowed.
He comes back to town.
And you can imagine how much
more worldly he would seem
and how much more, you
know, glamorous to Alice.
And she's educated and he's
sort of educated by the world.
And they decide to get married.
Well, then she has her
first child, Robert.
Who lives out in Suitland.
A delightful man who loves
his mother but was raised
by his grandparents
because it was tough times,
and for her to keep working as
a teacher, she took the help
from her parents to
raise the little boy.
So that was Charles Dunnigan.
But then the Depression came
and Charles didn't have a job.
And he couldn't stand the
shame of not being able
to support his family.
And so he leaves.
He kept leaving.
He'd come back and
then he'd leave again.
And so it was this system
really in both situations
that destroyed Alice's marriage.
It wasn't -- and
I'm telling you,
they were some good-looking
dudes.
But once you got past that,
there was nothing in common,
nothing to keep the marriage
together and keep it going,
although she tried very hard.
Any more questions?
Well, I'm sure if
you read this book --
and I can say since
I didn't write it,
I only took the machete
and cut it shorter
so that people would read it.
I can say, you will fall in
love with Alice Dunnigan.
Thank you.
[ Applause ]
>> Well, Carol, you've shared
not only the period of time
in which this all occurred but
you've shared a lot of yourself
that went into this book,
and we thank you for it.
And we don't care if it was a
machete or a pair of scissors,
you've brought her to life.
And it's wonderful
to have you back.
Now, there is going to be
a book signing in the back.
And please have a chance to
talk to Carol a little more.
And it's been a pleasure
to have you here.
Outside on the table
there's also a schedule
of future events coming up
for the Center for the Book
and also a issue of the new
Library of Congress Magazine,
which got put out just in
time for the Book Festival.
It's a quarterly, but it's
devoted to the joy of reading.
And a good chunk of that is
about, what, promoting reading
and promoting books and
writing and writers and people
like the person -- the
editor that we just met.
So thanks for joining us.
Pick up this.
And let's give a final
round of applause to Carol.
[ Applause ]
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at LOC.gov.